Se nos pide utilizar el menú desplegable para formar una ecuación lineal con una infinidad de soluciones.
Una ecuación lineal con un número infinito
de soluciones esencialmente tiene lo mismo
de los dos lados de la ecuación, no importa cuál sea el valor de "x" que escojamos para resolverla.
Y lo primero que quiero hacer es simplificar
un poco el lado izquierdo y luego ingeniar,
que hay que hacer para que el lado derecho
quede igual que el lado izquierdo.
Si distribuimos este 4 entre "x" menos 2,
tenemos "4x" menos 8 y le sumamos esta "x"
y esto va a ser igual a "5x" más algo y aquí
dejo un espacio en blanco, lo que tengo que
hacer es escoger el número correcto para
este espacio en blanco.
Entonces de este lado tengo que "4x" más
"x" es igual a "5x" menos 8
y del lado derecho tengo "5x" más espacio.
¿Y qué ponemos en este espacio para que
esto sea verdadero para cualquier valor de "x" ?
Aquí tenemos "5x" menos 8 y del lado derecho tenemos "5x" y si ponemos 8 negativo,
haremos que esto sea verdadero para
cualquier valor de "x" que escojamos.
Así es que vamos a escribir -8, para cualquier valor de "x" que multipliquemos por 5 y le restemos 8,
el resultado será igual a ese valor de "x"
multiplicado por 5 y restarle 8.
Y si quisieran resolver esto restando "5x"
de los dos lados de la ecuación obtendríamos
que 8 negativo es igual a 8 negativo, lo que es totalmente verdadero para cualquier valor de "x".
Así que vamos a completar este ejercicio.
Y hacemos "5x" más 8 negativo.